mr speaker
i know that members across the house
share my concern about the situation in
afghanistan
the issues it raises for our own
security and the fears of many remaining
in that country especially women and
children
the sacrifice in afghanistan is seared
into our national consciousness
with 150 000 people
serving there from across the length and
breadth
of the united kingdom
including a number of members
on all sides of the house whose voices
will be particularly important today
and so it's absolutely right that we
should come together for this debate and
mr speaker yes i uh will certainly give
way to my right honourable friend
i thank the prime minister for giving
way as someone who opposed this
nation-building
intervention it now brings its
responsibilities
in or in addition to getting our
nationals out safely and in offering a
generous welcome to the many refugees
will the prime minister assure me that
all necessary resources are given to
those afghans and others who have helped
the british council in its work
including the promotion
of women's rights
because many are in fear of their lives
of retribution from the taliban the arab
scheme is slow moving at the moment will
he commit the necessary resource because
the window of opportunity is narrow and
no one must be left behind
can i just remind people if you are
going to convene you've got to be short
if you'd intervene more than twice
you'll understand why you've gone down
the list if there was one prime minister
uh
i thank my honorable friend i should i
can i can assure him that i will uh and
as i will be saying in just a few
moments we will be supporting uh doing
everything we can to support those who
have helped
the uk mission in afghanistan and
investing everything that we can to
support the the wider area around uh
afghanistan and to do everything we can
to avert a humanitarian crisis mr
speaker it's almost 20 years since the
united states suffered the most
catastrophic attack on its people
since the second world war in which 67
british citizens also lost their lives
at the hands of murderous terrorist
groups incubated in afghanistan
in response
nato invoked article 5 of its treaty for
the first and only time
in its history
and the united kingdom amongst others
joined america in going into afghanistan
on a mission to extirpate al-qaeda in
that country and to do whatever we could
to stabilize afghanistan in spite of all
the difficulties and challenges we knew
that we would face and we succeeded in
that core mission and yes i will uh give
way to my runaway friend
i'm grateful mr speaker but would he
agree that we are actually ceding back
the country to the very insurgency that
we went into defeat
in the first place and the reputation of
the west to support democracies across
the world has suffered there are so many
lessons to be learned from what happened
over the last 20 years
will he now agree to an independent
formal inquiry into the conduct in
afghanistan
[Music]
mr speaker as i said in the house just a
few weeks ago there was an extensive uh
defense review about the afghan mission
after the combat mission ended in 2014
and i believe that most of the key
questions have already been extensively
gone into and it's important mr speaker
that we in this house should today be
able to scrutinize events as they unfold
as i was saying mr speaker we succeeded
in that core mission and the training
camps in the mountain ranges of
afghanistan were destroyed al-qaeda
plots against his country were foiled
because our serving men and women
were there
and no successful terrorist attacks
against the west have been mounted from
afghan soil for two decades
uh happily give way to my right on the
front prime minister can i just take him
back to his remarks in the house of july
the eighth when he referred to
uh the assessment that he'd made there's
clearly been a catastrophic failure of
our intelligence or our assessment of
the intelligence because of the speed
that this has
caught us unawares can the prime
minister set out for the house how we
may assure ourselves that in future
years we can
make sure there are no future terrorist
attacks
put together in afghanistan that take
place here in the united kingdom
uh mr speaker i'm i i think it'd be fair
to say that the events in afghanistan
have unfolded and the collapse has been
faster than i think even though the
taliban themselves predicted what is not
true is to say that the uk government uh
was unprepared or did not foresee this
because uh it was certainly part of our
planning of pitting the very difficult
uh logistical operation for the
withdrawal
of
uk nationals has been under preparation
uh for many months mr speaker and i can
tell the house that the
decision to commission the emergency
handling center at the airport the
commissioning of that center took place
uh two weeks ago mr speaker so
i if i would just if i can just uh make
a little bit more progress uh mr speaker
just a little bit i will certainly give
away in a moment
alongside
this core mission
we worked for a better future for the
people of afghanistan and the heroism
and tireless work of our armed forces
contributed to national elections
as well as the promotion and protection
of human rights and equalities in a way
that many in afghanistan had not
previously known
whereas 20 years ago almost no girls
went to school and women were banned
from positions of governance
now 3.6 million girls have been in
school this year alone
and women hold over a quarter of the
seats in afghan in the afghan parliament
but mr speaker we must be honest
and accept that huge difficulties were
encountered at each turn and some of
this progress is fragile i will give way
to the honorable gentleman i think the
prime minister they're doing away
i pay tribute to our ambassador and the
diplomatic team in kabul and our armed
forces on the ground who have been
evacuating people in extraordinary
circumstances but one of the
consequences of the rapidity of the
collapse of kabul is that many people
have been left trapped unable to access
the airport unable to evacuate including
many of those who should be coming to
this country who served us bravely in
that country and many women who are
particularly at risk many of us across
this house would have experienced chaos
in the last 24 48 hours in communicating
information through to the ground to get
some of those people out of the country
so can the prime minister give us some
assurances about how we can get that
information through so that we can get
those brave people out of there
including many at risk of their lives
right now in kabul
well he honorable gentleman raises
exactly the right uh question i spoke
this morning to ambassador solori
bristow as well as to brigadier uh dan
blanford who's handling the uh the
evacuation and it'd be fair to say the
situation has stabilized since uh the
weekend but it remains uh precarious
and the uk
uh
officials on the ground are doing
everything that they can to expedite the
movement of people those that need to
come out whether from the arab scheme or
the eligible
persons to get from kabul to
to the airport and at the moment it
would be fair to say that the taliban
are allowing that evacuation uh to go
ahead but the most important the most
important thing mr speaker is that we
get this done in as expeditious a
fashion as we can and that's what we are
doing and i may say that i'm grateful uh
not just to uh the
uk forces who are now out there helping
to stabilize the airport but also to the
us forces as well
does he agree with me that we have to do
everything we can to support those who
have supported us like the royal marine
pen farthing and his um nasa charity of
veterinary staff and their immediate
family who now need safe passage back to
the uk
mr speaker i think like many of us i
have been extensively lobbied on behalf
of uh the excellent work done by uh mr
penn father i'm well aware of uh his his
calls and all the wonderful things that
he he has done and for uh for animals in
uh in afghanistan i can tell uh my old
friend that we will do everything we can
to help uh mr penn farthing and others
who face particular difficulty
like uh like himself and
but as i say without in any way
jeopardizing our own national security
these are concerns shared across the
international community from the region
itself to all the nato alliance and
indeed all five permanent members of the
un security council
and i will chair a virtual meeting of
the g7 in the coming days
third mr speaker
we also have in a minute we also have an
enduring commitment to all the afghan
people
and now more than ever we must reaffirm
that commitment
our efforts must be focused on
supporting the afghan people in the
region itself particularly those fleeing
conflict or the threat of violence
we therefore call on the united nations
to lead a new humanitarian effort in
this region and i give way to the right
honourable lady officer
i thank the prime minister for giving
way and i welcome his commitment to
support in the region and also the
government's commitment to a
resettlement program but could he
confirm the home secretary announced in
2019 that the uk would continue a
resettlement scheme of 5 000 refugees a
year after the syrian scheme closed
could he confirm that the announcement
today of an afghan resettlement scheme
is in addition to that existing 5 000
resettlement commitment
as opposed to simply being a refocusing
or a displacement of that existing 5 000
a year resettlement program
i'm very grateful to the right
honourable lady opposite because i think
she's asked a question that uh formed
itself in many people's minds uh about
the the five thousands and yes uh indeed
the five thousand that uh extra and the
resettlement scheme are additional uh to
those already announced and we will
support uh those people in coming to
this country we will also support the
wider international community in
delivering on humanitarian projects in
the region
by doubling
doubling mr speaker the amount of
humanitarian and development assistance
that we had previously committed to
afghanistan this year
with new funding with new funding
the new weight print mr speaker taking
this up to 286 million pounds with
immediate effect
and we call on others 286 million pounds
with immediate effect we call on others
to work together on a shared
humanitarian effort
focusing on helping the most vulnerable
in what will be formidably difficult
circumstances and i i give way to my
radical friend i'm grateful to i'm
grateful to the prime minister and he's
being very generous with his time
over the past 20 years
there have been some 50 nato
and partner nations that have been
involved in afghanistan
i welcome the measures that have been
proposed by the uk and other countries
such as the u.s canada france germany
and so on
however
there are many countries still who have
been involved in afghanistan in recent
years who have still yet to come to the
plate and to recognize their
responsibility in helping these people
at this desperate time with the prime
minister inform the house what is being
done to encourage these other countries
to take up their responsibility and help
these people in afghanistan
uh my righteous friend makes an
excellent point mr speaker and that's
why uh the uk has uh chaired the
security council of the uh of the un and
asked to put motion together with our
french friends uh to get the world to
focus on the humanitarian needs of of
afghanistan will be doing the same thing
in all if in nato in in the g7 and the
other bodies in which we have a
leadership role and we want to we want
all these countries to step up as he
rightly says mr speaker and focus on the
most vulnerable in what will be
formidably difficult circumstances
fourth uh mr speaker i've given away i
think you'll agree uh quite a lot
already
this morning and
i know that uh thanks to uh the
generosity of the uh of yourself mr
speaker and the house there is now ample
time for debate until later on this
afternoon i think many members will be
able to uh get their points across i
therefore intend mr speaker buy or leave
to make some progress fourth while we
must focus on the region itself we will
also create safe and legal routes for
those afghans most in need to come and
settle here in the uk so in addition to
those afghans with whom we've worked
directly
i can announce today that we're
committing to relocating another 5 000
afghans this year with a new and bespoke
resettlement scheme focusing
on the most vulnerable particularly
women and children
and we will keep this under review for
future years
with the potential of accommodating up
to 20 000 over the long term
and so taken together mr speaker mr
speaker i've been very generous with my
interventions i think you will agree
already i've made my i made my position
clear taken together mr speaker we are
committing almost half a billion pounds
of humanitarian funding to support the
afghan people
fifth mr speaker we must also face the
reality of a change of regime in
afghanistan
and as president of the g7
the uk will work to unite the
international community behind a clear
plan for dealing with this regime in a
unified and concerted way over the last
three days i've spoken with the nato and
u.n secretary general with president
biden with chancellor merkel with
president macron and prime minister khan
we are clear
and
we have agreed
that it would be a mistake for any
country to recognize
any new regime in kabul prematurely
or bilaterally
instead
those countries that care about
afghanistan's future
should work towards common conditions
about the conduct of the new regime
before deciding together
whether to recognize it and on what
terms we will judge this regime based on
the choices it makes
and by its actions rather than by its
words
on its attitude to terrorism to crime
and narcotics as well as humanitarian
access and the rights of girls to
receive an education
defending human rights will remain of
the highest priority and we will use
every available political and diplomatic
means to ensure that those human rights
remain at the top of the international
agenda
mr speaker our united kingdom
has a role call of honor
that bears the names of 457 service men
and women
who gave their lives in some of the
world's harshest terrain
and many others who bear injuries to
this day
fighting in what had become the
epicenter of global terrorism
and even amid the heart-wrenching scenes
we see today i believe they should be
proud
of their achievements
and we should be deeply proud of them
because they conferred benefits
that are lasting
and inerradicable
on millions of people in one of the
poorest countries on earth
and they provided vital protection for
two decades
to this country and the rest of the
world
they gave their all
for our safety
and we owe it to them
to give our all to prevent afghanistan
from once again becoming a breeding
ground for terrorism
because no matter
no matter how grim
the lessons of the past
the future is not yet written
and at this bleak turning point we must
help the people of afghanistan to choose
the best of all their possible futures
and in the un the g7 in nato with
friends and partners around the world
that is the critical task on which this
government is now urgently engaged and
will be engaged in the days to come
[Applause]